there's been an awakening I've felt it
and no it's not the new Lizzie McGuire
reboot yes we finally have a Mandalorian
trailer and this one literally split my
insides in half in a good way so let's
not waste our time and take a deep dive
into this trailer and everything we know
so far now we do know that the
Mandalorian is set five years after the
Return of the Jedi after the fall of the
Empire but before the rise of the
first-order these bloody and dirty
stormtrooper helmets here shouldn't be
of any surprise since the empire is no
more and with a complete power vacuum
this world is set in will be one of
lawlessness and turmoil as various
groups fie for power we get a quick shot
of the Mandalorian here and we know it's
him because of these silver charges on
his left foot which we've seen unveiled
today at d23 more ominous heads on
spikes but you can quickly catch the
backside of the Mandalorians helmet but
here's what's interesting the yellow
tinge on the back right side if you see
the Mandalorians real helmet and also
the back side in other shots there's no
yellow marking so it's possible he's had
to put this on to signify some sort of
Allegiance and when you're entering a
place with heads on spikes that might be
a good thing now we could take a guess
as to which planet this is but creator
jon favreau has said that this series
will feature many new planets and races
but just because they're new they will
still have that Star Wars feel so keep
that in mind as we continue on with this
trailer and here we have a first glimpse
of the Mandalorian spaceship called the
razor crest which was unveiled at the
2019 Star Wars Celebration in Chicago as
far as I know this is not CG this is an
actual model superimposed among the
background of a still unknown planet
here's a better shot of the razor crest
with a Mandalorian just being dwarfed by
the giant rectangular rune and we have
these domed Tatooine s structures in the
back the ship on the right is most
likely another bounty hunters ship as
we'll see in the next few shot the
Mandalorian meets grief carga played by
Carl Weathers who is the leader of a
bounty hunter guild who hires the
Mandalorian to track a valuable asset
and in that next shot we seem to see the
Mandalorian returning that valuable
asset alongside a pile
of credits and this unknown object the
way it's edited makes me feel like the
mandalorian has a choice of reward
either being their credits or this
object and him taking this object is
something personal to him just take a
look at griefs face as he makes his
decision more beautiful shots of the
razor crests navigating a barren cracked
planet when we get a bunch of quick
shots of the Mandalorians armor here we
have him putting a knife back into his
right leg armor piece him adjusting his
wrist plates note more charges attached
to his chest as he prepares to disembark
a more forested planet in the concept
art shown at Star Wars Celebration
there's a forested planet that shows an
entirely new race here that the
Mandalorian will likely interact with
here's our first shot of Kara doom we
don't know much about her other than
she's an ex rebel shock trooper and will
feature as one of the main characters in
the story and here we have the
Mandalorian yet again notice this time
no yellow marking on the back of his
helmet like we had in the first few
shots this short dude over here is still
to be named but we've seen him and these
new creatures as part of the Star Wars
Celebration concept art notice the dead
creature on the left which may or may
not have been a result of the
Mandalorian hence this rider with his
gun out now I love this shot here it
just feels so Star Wars here we have a
female Twilight character brandishing a
knife but look behind her that looks a
lot like Bill burr who has been cast in
the show as an outlaw and considering
the company he's in this is likely some
sort of outlaw hangar gorgeous shot here
of the Mandalorian amongst the sunset
simultaneously conjuring images of a new
hope while showing the solitary life of
a bounty hunter it's also worth
mentioning here that the cinematography
is done by Greg Fraser who also did the
cinematography for row 1 and this next
image here screams the first 10 minutes
of that film now we don't know who these
two are but they are obviously hiding
from someone and this woman is trying to
protect the child if I were to take a
random guess this is a flashback of the
Mandalorian as a child with his mother
with an entire season to fill the show
will undoubtedly go into how the
Mandalorian became a bounty hunter a man
with no family eking out a dangerous
life on the edge of the galaxy this next
shot here looks as though they're
shooting at the woman and child but it's
an editing fake out the background
really doesn't match
this is likely an altercation in one of
the trade towns and these troopers here
are under the control of Giancarlo
Esposito zkk Erik tur we don't have a
name for his character yet but in an
interview with slash film he said the
following in a way you might call him an
underworld character you may also look
at him as a savior as someone who might
bring back some order to the world after
it's all collapsed so it's not known
whether he's some sort of Imperial
commander trying to keep his soldiers
together or the leader of a world which
is now impoverished after the defeat of
the Empire and here is our first full-on
face shot of the Mandalorian a
particular note here is the butt end of
his rifle which was shared on Instagram
by Jon Favreau in October of last year
November 12th the release date on Disney
Plus Disney's new online platform
similar to Netflix and that date can't
come fast enough here we have two
characters and what appears to be a
flare looking for rescue and someone
coming to help riding an imperial
speeder with the defeat of the Empire
it's likely we'll see many imperial
weapons machines and ships fall into the
hands of some interesting characters and
here we have a good old fashioned 80s
tea you likely mowing down targets on
the same planet we saw in the last shot
we have a bunch of innocent civilians
fleeing attack and a close-up shot of
this boy and his father heading to
safety I'm gonna go out on a limb here
and this again could be kid Mandalorian
I also forgot to mention that adult
Mandalorian is played by Game of Thrones
favorite Pedro Pascal and I can't help
but see a little resemblance there and
here's our first shot of IG 11 and the
Mandalorian having kicked their way into
a yet to be disclosed building IG 11
shouldn't be confused with ig-88 who is
first seen in the Empire Strikes Back
11 will be voiced by take away TT who
directed thor ragnarok and here is where
we get into a bunch of action shots near
the end of the trailer to get everyone
pumped here's the razor crest taking a
hit from a pursuing ship the Mandalorian
blasting the [ __ ] out of attacking men
on rooftops leading me to believe this
was some sort of ambush and IG 11
absolutely blasting the [ __ ] out of
their attackers there's also a standoff
between the Mandalorian and a few
stormtroopers followed by the voice of
Verner Hertzog fun fact Verner has never
seen any of the Star
movies now I've seen the leaked footage
of the scene and he definitely is a
villain who controls these stormtroopers
and gives the Mandalorian his main quest
for the season there is also a crazy
theory out there that he is actually in
old version of Bubba Fett who survived
the Sarlacc pit he has also said that
his role is very small which likely
means he'll get offed early on we also
have some ruffians being taken care of
in a bar including this dude who gets
sliced in half but notice also that
we're on some sort of snow planet here
in this brief trailer we've already seen
multiple planets varying ecosystems so
it's likely we'll be following the
mandalorian all over the galaxy ah and
Carbonite who can forget that substance
han Solo was frozen in for years
we have this dude and alien who we can
only assume is one of the Mandalorians
bounties he's bringing back since we can
see him in the back left corner of the
screen
so it's possible if the Mandalorian is
tasked with bringing someone back alive
he could have them frozen as proof of
capture I don't know about you guys but
I am totally stoked for this more so
than any other Star Wars project in the
last 20 years if you want me to keep
covering Star Wars give the video a like
leave a comment and make sure to
subscribe you can also follow me on
twitter at things story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much